I made fun of them for as women weren't
allowed to drive and Saturday and I was
going in on it I'm like well maybe you
should let the women Drive cuz you guys
drive like you know and then sounds
like oh my god this is payback I'm gonna
lose my head and they're gonna blame
Isis or some right
[Music]
super stoked to get this guy everybody
loves it one of the biggest
comments in the world to be honest
please give it up for mr. Russell Peters
everybody I've been doing standing for
27 years so and when you're doing it
this long and and you start to progress
things in your life changed like my
situation changed from being this broke
brown kid in Canada to do an okay kid in
LA now right or or old ass man but
whatever and I get to go around the
world that's the beauty of what I do for
a living is I get to go around the world
and I go to places that the American
media tells you not to go to because
they want you to be scared and keep your
mustache like that so recently I was in
the Middle East I can't say which
country because I signed an NDA but but
I was there I did a show in in this
place in the Middle East well I could
say this I was in the Saudi Arabia and
and it was very different I'd never been
to Saudi Arabia before because I was
always scared to go to Saudi Arabia
everybody was like sorry baby I'm like
you and and that's based on
watching the news in America and I'm
like boy you better not go to Saudi
Arabia or they'll tie it at two
different camels and they'll make them
run away and I mean that that's all you
ever hear about Saudi Arabia is that
torture and beheadings and they kill you
and you watch what you say and that's
all true but but you don't see it in the
Middle East it's very quiet so don't
don't tell anyone what we do so anyway I
do the show they're great had a great
time there's 10,000 Prince's in Saudi
Arabia so there's a lot of
royalty just running around Saudi Arabia
so I do a show
I'm tripped out because when I get on
stage the audience is segregated not not
like this not like hipsters on one side
and you know like but it's like it's
women on one side and men on the other
and because they're not allowed to be
together and I was like why can't the
women be together with the men there
this is the honest answer I got I
thought it was hilarious I go
hey why can't the women and the men be
together because they'll go crazy want
to everybody hey it's not the men
that are gonna go crazy just so you're
aware of this these women are lunatics
apparently everybody right so go all
right a good plan right and so we do the
show and then one of the other princes
who was a little more higher up I guess
in the prince hierarchy hears about the
show and tells the other Prince I guess
who's this cousin and he goes I want to
private show with Russell and then he
comes to me at the see they have this
little after-party for me and you would
think like you're like alright you know
cuz its Saudi Arabia they're gonna be
like this mad bitches they got the doors
closed two chicks in the whole
room and they're like sisters of
somebody in there right you're like God
come on guy and then there's guys guys
are dancing with guys it's not it's
weird it's not like but it's not like
here you know cuz over here in a minim
erika we've lost the idea of what
dancing is you know white people have
won the dancing war I mean let's be
honest like when you go to like an EDM
thing everybody's just jumping up and
down and nobody's dancing anymore that
means white people won and it's either
that or you're just ass
everybody all night and I mean then so
when I say the guys are dancing on each
other they're not like here but I'll do
it you know like they're just I'm not
exaggerating there was a dude doing a
dance it looks like a camel that's what
that's what his dead his dance was this
use the I was I guess that how
you pick up chicks over here well well
in the hump or two you know and then so
anyway the other Prince calls this
prince and he's like private show
tomorrow and and then my brother who's
my manager is like are well let me talk
to him and when you sort the details out
and I go I go I go I'm scared about this
cuz we're already here and you know we
already don't know enough about these
people but honey and then he comes over
and he talks to him and he's like oh
that's a lot of money and so I go
oh yeah we'll do that show alright and
then my brother goes okay well we're
gonna need lights we're gonna need the
cameraman we're gonna need the DJs we're
gonna need the opening act and he's like
no just Russell and I'm like oh all
right and it goes has to be private
event and I go alright well can you give
me any information no information I'm
like well how many people he goes it's a
very small party for the blintze and I'm
like okay and I'm thinking small alright
private thing maybe 50 200 people right
I've done worse 27 years of stand-up
I've done shows where there's two people
in the audience I literally put the mic
down and just sat with them I was like
it's stupid for me to try and
what are you do you know so so I go how
many people and they go maybe 10 to 12
I'm like oh come on guy right this is
ridiculous
and then my brother goes through to do
and I go that's a lot of money yeah
you're right let's let's do it so I go
to the palace the next day right
and I get there and they put us in like
a waiting room and then they this guy
comes in it goes mr. Dubey toes please
and I and my brother and I cuz you know
obviously he's got the same last name
hey we both get up and he goes no no you
stay just him and and I'm thinking
graham gonna get beheaded or some
right cuz i talked mad the night
before right i I made fun of them for
his women weren't allowed to drive
inside it's illegal for women to drive
inside Arabia and I was going in on it
I'm like well maybe you should let the
women Drive cuz you guys drive like
you know and then
it sounds like oh my god this is payback
I'm gonna lose my head and they're gonna
blame Isis or some right so
so I go into this room and it's a little
ass room with a hundred and ten inch TV
and I walk in and I figure cuz the TV
say this is the TV behind me I walk in
the room and I'm like alright I guess
I'll just stand in front of this TV and
do my little jokes for these eleven
people that are here and I walk in and
then the prince is sitting in the middle
of the room and he gets up and he goes
hey thanks for coming he doesn't sound
like how you're thinking he's gonna look
blue the blue them to attend my friends
you know he's like hey thanks for coming
and I'm like what the fuck's happening
right now like Ashton Kutcher is gonna
come out ha ha
so he goes he goes sit down Russell
please sit down so I sit down and I just
start making fun of everybody in the
room literally like I'm like you BAM you
BAM then and then the prince is like
feeding me lines that guy owns camels
and I'm like
dude camel guy and how's it going
and then I don't know if that's the
greeting or the dance right so you know
the the prince I'm making fun of my I'm
starting I start making from the prince
I got a I got a little carried
away and I knew when I was getting
carried away because I already went
everybody else no problem but then the
Prince says to me there's a guy sitting
beside me and he goes hey Russell
that guy has one of the only brown
diamonds in the world and I go what the
is a brown diamond he goes show him
show him the guy takes off his ring and
he's got this little tiny ass brown
diamond on a ring right and I go oh cool
and I go to put it on my hand and it
wouldn't go past my pinkie nail and I'm
like how smaller your hands and I look
at the prince and I go this guy's got
childlike hands and the prince starts
laughing and then as a as a joke I
grabbed the guy's wrist right and I have
friends that are magicians and they
taught me how to take a watch of
somebody's wrist so I grabbed his wrist
and I unlock his watch and I pull it off
and I go how small your wrist and then I
go oh wow
nice watch I go what is that a Richard
Mille a goes knows who blow and I go
hone ice I go here goes keep it and I'm
like okay buddy so I put I put the watch
on and I'm doing I start talking again
that about ten minutes later I go hey
man here's your watch he goes no no I
give to you and I'm like what the
so I start getting comfortable right I'm
cuz now I feel like I've done my job
everybody's laughed in this room and
then the prince goes come on let's eat
and I go alright let's eat so we go to
this other room to eat and I'm sitting
there and I go hey man where's the guy
that gave me the watch he goes oh he
left and I go but I've got his watch and
he goes he gave it to you and I go
alright and he goes that's how it is in
Saudi Arabia if you come if you like
something we have and you say I like
that we have to give it to you and I go
wow
this is the best palace I've ever been
in didn't work doesn't work on real
estate apparently I should have
complimented the rolls-royce they sent
to pick me up in the goddamnit I
that went up right so so I started you
know the prince is really cool so I
start talking to him I'm like yo did you
know Osama bin Laden cuz he was from
South Arabia and I go did you know sama
bin Laden goes well I didn't know him
but I know his family
I go really he goes yeah I mean he's
much older than I am I go yeah I guess
that makes sense cuz it but his family
is a very prominent family here in Saudi
Arabia they're there the they built
Saudi Arabia they were the construction
company that built it he goes he went
crazy he went that way and the family
was this way and he was mad at Saudi
Arabia and he was mad at his family so
he went a little cuckoo and then
I was like that's amazing because he's
very have you think about the breakdown
of Osama bin Laden
he's very similar to Donald Trump he's
he's the spoiled brats billionaires son
of a developer who's mad at
everybody
so I go I go it goes yeah his family is
very nice actually and I go really goes
do you want to meet his brother and I'm
like yeah I wanna meet his brother so so
he goes okay he says to some random I
don't know what he's saying but okay
sure right and then so the next day I
get this call at my hotel and they send
the car the the prince sends a car for
me and he go what's this for he goes oh
you said do you want it to go see Saudi
Arabia so he sent a car so he can go
around and see everything and he walks
out with me and he's on his phone he's
like uh-huh uh-huh and he goes hey do
you still want to meet osama's brother
and I'm like yeah he goes okay one
sec here oh my god what's this and I
won't say with the guys first name cuz
you know that'll give it away but uh but
it says blank bin Laden on the phone
right and I'm like I go what's this he
goes it's Osama's brother and I go holy
so I go hello and it goes and
that's exactly here's what you're
expecting right Osama bin Laden's
brother to go on the one leg bro son
what are you doing infidel right
I go hello and this is what I hear on
the other end
hey Russell I go it goes yeah it's yeah
I'm blah blah blah bin Laden I go yeah
and see that on the phone he goes first
of all me tell you a big fan of your
stuff and I'm like what the good is
going on over here right and he's like
um how long you in town for go I'm
leaving today cuz yeah I'm flying back
tonight uh man I'm gonna miss you
hey stay in touch with me take my number
and I'm like what yeah take my number
and I go alright and I go just so you
know your name's going in is Dave Smith
on my phone thank you guys you were
great
[Applause]